on est toujours dans l'est de l'ukraine
à la frontière avec la russie bonjour
romeo 50 bombardements ont été recensés
en 24 heures dans cette grande ville de
l'ukraine quelle est la situation
oui ici à kharkiv les combats continuent
les bombardements d' sont permanents de
selon de nombreux habitants il y amène
de plus en plus de bombardements sans
vraiment que les troupes russes ont
décidé de pilonner kharkiv jour et nuit
afin de prendre la vie d'alors selon un
bilan
fourni aujourd'hui par le gouverneur de
la région de l'oblast de kharkiv et bien
il y a eu ces 24 dernières heures quatre
morts à kharkhiv de nombreux blessés et
dans le village de tchimou yves il ya eu
deux morts donc les gens sont
effectivement extrêmement anxieux ils se
rendent bien compte que la dîmière
poutine qui a battu en retraite à kiev
est en train de réorganiser les troupes
dans la région de karkhiv c'est
l'information que nous avions déjà
depuis plusieurs jours c'est ce que
craignait c'est ce que santé les gens
d'ici c'est ce que nos sources nous nous
laisser comprendre cette information a
été confirmée par plusieurs os au par
des officiels l'ukrainien qui confirme
qu'effectivement les troupes sont en
train d'encercler d'essayer d'encercler
la ville de kharkiv qui est soumis donc
à des bombardements absolument
incessants où on est là la contre
attaque là contre résistance la
résistance plutôt romeo perdons
la résistance et permanente c'est
d'abord bien sûr une résistance
militaire de la porte des forces du
craignait alors il est très difficile de
savoir sur le terrain car l'accès au
front et très fermé
très dangereux et surtout les ukrainiens
sont extrêmement soucieux de laisser à
filtrer un minimum d'information de
nombreux officiels nous ont dit qu'ils
avaient l'information selon laquelle la
les russes utiliser considérablement les
réseaux sociaux afin d'essayer d'établir
les positions de l'ennemi donc difficile
de se rendre sur le front ce qui est
certain c'est que dans la zone de mal à
roanne et autour du village de chief ces
dernières semaines le les forces
d'ukraine ont repris un peu de terrain
mais un peu plus à l'est autour de la
localité 10 um qui est intensément
pilonnée par l'armée russe eh bien il
semble que la russie soit clairement à
l'offensive gagne du terrain tente donc
de contourner le vie à la ville de
chihuahua pour essayer de se rapprocher
de la ville de kharkiv est bien sûr il
ya également une menace qui est en train
de se former un peu plus à l'est dans le
donbass donc cette partie
orientale de l'ukraine une menace
notamment autour de la ville de cramât
tort sq donc les gens ici à kharkiv sont
extrêmement inquiets voilà maintenant
bientôt un mois et demi qu'ils vivent
nuitées jours sous les bombes au moins
de 300 personnes peut-être beaucoup plus
sont mortes dans des bombardements les
gens sont inquiets car ils s'ils ont
réussi à empêcher l'armée russe au début
de l'offensive de prendre car qui dit
ils se rendent compte que l'offensive
continue qu'une nouvelle bataille
s'annonce qu'elle pourrait être terrible
ils sont extrêmement anxieux pour
l'instant environ un tiers des habitants
ont quitté la ville mais ses habitants
essaient de vivre sous les bombes
essaient de résister mais ils sont bien
sûr dans un état de stress absolument
permanent